[Music]
hey guys it's quinn here if you
appreciate my content please consider
hitting the like button it's really the
only way that the youtube algorithm
takes notice of my videos thanks guys
one of the key facts about human beings
is that each of us are individuals and
yet we live in societies which sometimes
act as super organisms
it is very difficult for one individual
to steer the course of the whole species
this is sometimes a good thing there are
moments that the human spirit seems to
join together as one and great things
can be accomplished
and this is sometimes also a bad thing
for example
man-led climate change is an issue that
scientists have known about for quite
some time but the human entity runs on
oil
the actions of a single individual would
have little impact to slow the rate of
change
the organism moves on its own
even if everyone watching this video
somehow finds a way to never contribute
to fossil fuel emissions ever again for
the rest of their lives this would
essentially do nothing because the human
entity is far too large
this is much akin to how the individual
cells in your body make up you but the
individual cells themselves have no say
over your actions
individuality itself is often heralded
as one of the virtues of mankind but
individuality is also the cause of much
of the turmoil in human society
individuality leads to chaos
though many would argue that this is a
necessary vice of a free society
individuality and free expression are
part of what makes life worth living
often when free expression and
individuality are stripped as in both
the modern and historical fascist
regimes of earth societal well-being in
general goes down dramatically
fascism does not breed progress of any
kind
under these types of structures the soul
of mankind bleeds
the happiest societies in the world
emphasize individuality and freedom
beyond personal individuality humans
also have a tendency to break themselves
into groups
sometimes based on traits that members
of that group share
sometimes based on geographical
association
different groups of humans often find
themselves at odds competing for
resources and power of all forms
with such groupings prejudices also form
and as these groups persist throughout
time
generational prejudices form and the
differences between groups of humans
start to be distorted in the eyes of
opposing groups
this of course leads to many problems in
society
if mankind could view itself as a
homogeneous group not divided by
arbitrary lines the things we could
accomplish could be great
isaac asimov deals with some of these
ideas in his foundation book series
and that is mainly what we are here to
talk about today
isaac asimov has long been accepted as
one of the greatest science fiction
authors of all time
his expansive vision of humanity's
future came to life almost 80 years ago
with the publication of the first short
story in his foundation series
after it was all done there were a total
of seven books in the series itself and
the final two books deal with the
potential ultimate fate of mankind
according to asimov's work humankind had
the potential to exist sustainably in
three ways
the first two are as follows
through technological development as was
the way of the first foundation
or through the honing of metallic
abilities as was the way of the second
foundation
both these institutions had been created
by harry selden and given ultimate
secret goals
the first foundation resided on the
world of terminus and the second
foundation resided on the world of
trantor which had once been the center
of the first empire
the first foundation was supreme in the
realm of physical power of technology of
war weapons
the second foundation was supreme in the
realm of mental power of the mind of the
ability to control
in any conflict between the two what
would it matter how many ships and
weapons the first foundation disposed of
if the second foundation could control
the minds of those who control the ships
and weapons
the third way that humans could exist
sustainably however was through
humanity's merging as a single entity
as was the way of the people of the
conscious planet gaia
who had hoped that one day humankind
could merge into one female entity the
super being known as galaxia
they believed that by merging into one
mind with one goal humanity could most
effectively deal with potential outside
threats
the second galactic empire worked out
after the fashion of trantor will be a
paternalistic empire established by
calculation maintained by calculation
and in perpetual living death by
calculation it will be a dead end this
is the view of gaia travis said and what
does gaia have to offer as an
alternative
greater gaia galaxia
every inhabited planet as alive as gaia
every living planet combined into a
still greater hyperspatial life every
uninhabited planet participating every
star every scrap of interstellar gas
perhaps even the great central black
hole
a living galaxy and one that can be made
favorable for all life in ways that we
yet cannot foresee
a way of life fundamentally different
from all that has gone before and
repeating none of the old mistakes
in the foundation saga golan travis
ultimately holds the threads of human
fate
this was a responsibility that he did
not ask for
it was a decision that was forced upon
him because he suspected the existence
of the second foundation and openly
questioned harry selden's great plan he
was banished from the first foundation
about 500 years after the fall of the
first empire
he eventually encounters the world of
gaia
and it was after discovering this world
that he decides the fate of mankind
choosing galaxia the super organism
initially he chose galaxia because he
believed the slow progress of galaxia's
development would give him time to
change his mind if he should find that
it was not the right path for humanity
it is in the book foundation and earth
that he accepts that he has truly made
the right choice
i
we
gaia know you are that is your work to
us you have the capacity for making the
right decision on incomplete data and
you have made the decision you chose
gaia you rejected the anarchy of a
galactic empire built on the technology
of the first foundation
as well as the anarchy of a galactic
empire built on the mentalix of the
second foundation
you decided that neither could be long
stable you chose gaia
galaxia would eventually encompass the
entire milky way
uniting all humankind uniting all life
the milky way galaxy had given birth to
just a single species with sufficient
intelligence to develop a
technologically advanced society but
they knew almost nothing of other
galaxies
travis speculated that the milky way
could be atypical
that other galaxies might possess
multiple competing intelligent species
he believed that their preoccupation
with each other prevented them from
turning their eyes onto other galaxies
but he speculated that in some galaxy
one species may gain dominance and then
they may consider the possibility of
invading into other galaxies such as the
milky way
we have not visited any other galaxy and
as far as we know no intelligent species
from another galaxy has ever visited us
but that state of affairs may end
someday
and if the invaders come they are bound
to find ways of turning some human
beings against other human beings
we have so long had only ourselves to
fight that we are used to such
internecine quarrels an invader that
finds us divided against ourselves will
dominate us all or destroy assault the
only true defense is to produce galaxia
which cannot be turned against itself
and which can meet invaders with maximum
power
although golan travis voiced the
decision the decision was in truth not
actually his
the decision had been made long ago
in the book foundation and earth the
last official book in asimov's
foundation series
it is revealed that the robot denil
oliva has been responsible for many of
the events of the last several centuries
he had been manipulating the citizens of
the milky way and steering the course of
human events from a base on the moon of
old earth leaving sometimes in disguise
to accomplish specific goals it had been
daniel that set events up so that
humankind would ultimately choose
galaxia greatly increasing their chances
of survival should an alien threat
appear
denial had been operating based on
asimov's laws of robotics for nearly 20
000 years
i've done a video covering this
character specifically as well as
asimov's laws of robotics here
essentially many science fiction stories
have ideas involving the merging
together of the human species in a kind
of hive mind
sometimes this is viewed optimistically
like in the work of asimov and other
times there are sinister undertones
the hive-minded beings which appear in
the star trek universe known as the borg
for instance
the borg seek only to assimilate species
and technology which they find useful
in doing so they forcefully eliminate
all individuality from those they force
into their collective or the harangans
from george rr martin's the thousand
worlds universe
like the borg they were made up of many
different assimilated species
they had been mankind's greatest enemy
during the centuries-long conflict known
as the double war
one of the great fears that is presented
with this idea as i mentioned earlier is
the thought that individuality would be
lost
our individual traits and thoughts are
what make us who we are
to have that stripped away would be akin
to death
but of course the optimistic view and
presented in asimov's work reads more
like an evolution of mankind as opposed
to mankind being minimized to become a
part of something else
what do you guys think about the idea of
all humankind merging together as one or
the idea of hive minds in general
what are some of your favorite examples
of this idea
let me know in the comment section down
below thank you guys so much
you